in three 2
[Music]
action so good good good
good bad name anyone but him I didn't
approve him you know that you are
literally the last person on Earth I
want to see slap the out of you I
really could and I'm open to that in a
safer
environment you been a ghost no phone
call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up stun gu
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guy
we need to to keep it profes profes is
my middle name you said your middle name
was
danger how do we do
boss really yeah holster that it's
holstered it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back Jody's movie is dead why me you're
a stump man nobody's going to notice you
that your job no offense I mean some
taking you find Ryder save Jody's film
you get the love of your life back I'm
not the hero I'm just the double not
today you're
not Tom we already need you back on set
pal
you
dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail he
was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I have no choice I had to do some
Jason boor
they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you can make it
you can make it you can't make it it's
too dangerous got to be stairs
okay what happened to your face you look
terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love I'll BL you drink when this is over
engage your
core yeah
boy you doing later want to go to a
beach somewhere drink a spicy Margarita
make some bad decisions
yes the heart and you're to
[Applause]
blame